bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre en séance l'examen
de la proposition de loi du député ump
eric ciotti qui prévoit un encadrement
de type militaire pour les mineurs
délinquants
cette proposition de loi a déjà été
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale mais
elle a été rejetée la semaine dernière
par la commission des lois du sénat à
mes côtés pour en parler virginie klès
sénatrice socialiste d'ille et vilaine
et rapporteur de ce texte bonjour alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qui a entraîné le rejet en commission de
cette proposition de loi
deux choses la première chose c'est
l'utilisation de ce texte de loi de 7,2
secondes
cette proposition pardon de loi pour y
rajouter un cavalier législatif
totalement inacceptables en matière de
réforme de la justice pénale des mineurs
sans aucune concertation avec les
professionnels concernés
ça c'est l'article 6 qui été rajoutées à
ce texte sur initiatives des
gouvernements
et la deuxième chose c'est le fait qu'on
ait absolument persuadés qu'il s'agit
d'un texte d'affichage un texte de
communication totalement inutile et qui
plus est néfaste à l'image de l'epide
établissement public d'insertion pour la
défense qui aujourd'hui réalisé un
excellent travail avec des jeunes
majeurs en insertion et qu'on veut
réutilisée sans aucune prise en compte
de la spécificité de l'établissement et
des jeunes qui sont accueillis pour soi
disant 'il y accueillir des mineurs
délinquants et donc casser quelque chose
qui marche et qui existe il ya donc
selon vous un risque de déstabilisation
des epide mais également une opposition
de principe donc à toute modification de
l'ordonnancé de 1945 qui protège les
mineurs délinquants aujourd'hui y'a pas
une
un refus systématique et dogmatique de
réformer l'ordonnancé de 45 au contraire
on le réclame depuis longtemps mais si
on doit réformer cette ordonnance au
lieu de le faire par petits coups on en
est je sais plus si c'est au sixième
bout à la 10eme modifications depuis
quelques années et on arrive à quelque
chose de totalement incohérents en plus
les modifications qui nous sont apportés
dans ce texte là sont de l'aveu même de
monsieur ciotti
des modifications destinées à calquer la
justice des mineurs sur celle des
majeurs
donc ça oui c'est totalement
inacceptable et par principe par contre
réformer l'ordonnancé de 45
ça pose pas de problème mais prenons le
texte dans son entièreté prenant le
temps de la concertation avec les
magistrats avec les professionnels de la
délinquance des mineurs et faisant les
choses correctement
quel va être le parcours législatif de
ce taxi
la motion qui va être défendue par vous
et puis par le groupe communiste cet
après midi est adopté si la motion de
rejet est adopté et bien nous sommes en
désaccord avec l'assemblée nationale il
y aura donc une commission mixte
paritaire dans cette commission mixte
paritaire c'est l'assemblée nationale
qui aura le dernier mot
pas forcément la commission mixte
paritaire fonctionne sur un règlement
intérieur extrêmement souple et et non
écrit donc on verra qui y sera envoyé
par l'assemblée nationale et on verra ce
qu'il en sortira ce moment là
jean-pierre mais l'avait dit lors de ce
nom de son élection qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'obstruction ici au sénat pourtant la
semaine dernière un texte a été rejeté
en séance sur le projet de loi sur les
agences des voies navigables et puis en
commission
cette ppl ciotti c'est pas un peu de
l'obstruction quand même c'est pas
l'instruction c'est la réaffirmation de
nos principes
ce sont des textes qui arrive un moment
où on est majoritaire avant il arrivait
alors que nous étions minoritaires ou
des textes similaires
on avait beau répondre qu'on était
opposé et argumentée notre opposition on
n'était pas entendue aujourd'hui on
continue exactement sur le même principe
en arguments de nos oppositions on a des
raisons d'être contre j'appelle pas ça
l'obstruction ce texte en crise que a
priori d'être rejetée ce soir en séance
mais j'espère vous avez mis des
amendements pour verrouiller de
suppression si la motion n'était pas
adoptée c'est ça c'est pas moi qui ai
mis les amendements c'est monsieur mais
a requis les qui les a déposés et bien
évidemment ne pouvait pas émettre un
avis défavorable puisqu'ils vont dans le
sens de ce que l'on souhaite donc
effectivement ils ont un texte accepté
ce matin par la commission des lois
merci beaucoup virginie klès je vous
laisse le regagné l'hémicycle du sénat
pour l'examen de cette proposition de
loi du député eric ciotti qui vise à
mettre en place un encadrement de type
militaire pour les mineurs délinquants
très bonne science à tous
la parole est à madame colette
giudicelli pour le groupe ump s'il vous
plaît
merci monsieur le président les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
dans son intervention de 1847 sur les
prisons ici même au sénat à la chambre
des pairs c'est comme ça là où victor
hugo affirmé m tout homme coupable est
une éducation menti qu'il faut refaire
la prison doit être une école je suis
sûr que moi cette parole nous
rassemblera pour dire combien cette
phrase prend tout son sens lorsque nous
évoquons la question de la délinquance
des mineurs
la délinquance des nouvelles dans notre
pays est un vrai sujet d'inquiétude
elle est le résultat de la conjonction
de plusieurs phénomènes
tout d'abord la progression j'ai
significative depuis plusieurs années du
nombre de délinquants mineurs n'est pas
contestable
il faut quand même rappeler que la part
des mineurs dans la délinquance globale
en 2010 et de 18,8 pour cent au total le
nombre de mineurs délinquants confiée à
la pj n'a cessé d'augmenter au cours des
dernières années + 44 % entre 2002 et
2010 dans mon département si l'on
constate une baisse assez forte de la
délinquance générale entre 2002 et 2010
de près de 19%
la délinquance des mineurs elles restent
encore à un niveau très élevé ces
éléments bien sûr lui tiennent pas
compte de l'explosion des incivilités
qui restent trop souvent impunies et
sont très mal vécues au quotidien par
nos concitoyens
cette plantation du nombre des
délinquants mineurs est associé à un
rajeunissement des auteurs des
infractions et à une aggravation des
actes de délinquance
les actes de violence des mineurs sont
passés de 6 % à 22 % des mises en cause
entre 2002 et 2010 il faut donc nous
pensions absolument arrêter ce processus
avant que certains m'ignore de vienne
lent et peut-être irrécupérable face à
ces jeunes primo délinquante
désocialisés en échec scolaire
confronté à la démission totale
quelquefois des parents nous devons
apporter de manière urgente et des
réponses spécifiques
bien évidemment nous devons continuer de
privilégier les mesures éducatives
plutôt que les dispositifs répressifs
comme l'imposent l'ordonnancé du 2
février 1945
cela exige bien sûr de mettre de
nombreux outils à la disposition d'une
autorité judiciaire
c'est une erreur de penser que
l'autorité judiciaire disposerait
aujourd'hui d'un éventail formidable de
solutions suffisamment large pour
répondre à toutes les situations
en dépit des différents dispositifs
existants les solutions apportées
finalement reste peu varié le contrat de
service citoyen n'est pas seulement une
alternative à la prison
le texte tel qu'il nous a été transmis
par l'assemblée nationale complète
utilement l'ensemble des dispositifs
existants entre d'un côté les foyers
classique et de l'autre des centres
éducatifs fermés que nous avons créé en
2002 le contrat de service citoyens
peuvent se défendre est effectivement le
chaînon qui manquait à notre réponse
pénale mais participera au processus de
re socialisation de ces primaires primo
délinquants il sera prononcé par le
magistrat au titre de la composition
pénale ou dans le cadre d'un ajournement
de peine ou même d'une peine
d'emprisonnement avec sursis accompagnés
d'un sursis de mise à l'épreuve alors
certes plusieurs questions se posent
pour mettre en oeuvre ce contrat de
service citoyen et est il souhaitable de
créer un nouveau type de centres de
discipline et de réinsertion
à côté des foyers d autres structures
d'accueil et des centres éducatifs
fermés
eh bien je partage totalement les points
de vue du député eric ciotti et du
gouvernement
il fallait tirer parti de l'est
distance et de l'expérience des epide
qui ont été créés en 2005
ces établissements assurent déjà
l'insertion sociale et professionnelle
des jeunes adultes en difficulté en
risque de marginalisation de volontaire
s'appuyant sur ce programme dispensé au
sein des epide
le contraste sur des citoyens s'est fixé
trois objectifs
une mise à niveau en français en
orthographe en mathématiques une
formation civique et comportementale et
une pré formation professionnelle ce
programme a démontré son efficacité
le taux de réussite dans les ep des de
plus de 80 % pour ceux qui ont eu le
courage d'aller jusqu'au bout du
parcours
deuxième question peut-on les langes et
des publics très différents
alors d'un côté on aurait deux jeunes
qui seraient volontaires pour s'en
sortir et de l'autre des jeunes
délinquants récupérables qui ne le
serait pas le contrat de service citoyen
ne s'adressera cas des mineurs âgés de
plus de 16 ans primo délinquants ou
ayant commis des faits d'une faible
gravité ayant surtout exprimer leur
consentement
le point essentiel de ce dispositif est
effectivement qu'il repose sur le
volontariat
il n'y a pas de réinsertion il n'existe
pas d'insertion possible sans l'adhésion
de l'intéressé dans ces câbles il est
essentiel que le juge s'assure de la
réelle adhésion du zinc concernés alors
faisons confiance à la justice pour
déceler le degré de leur motivation
contrairement à tout ce qu'on a entendu
la proposition de loi d'eric ciotti ne
dénaturent nullement la vocation
initiale des epide
pour deux raisons d'une part il ya
toujours été prévu que des gens
délivrant reste minoritaire dans les
epide
en réalité ils ne dépasseront pas plus
de 10% des effectifs de chaque centre
200 jeunes cela a été dit seront
concernés par an dans un premier temps
et dès février 2012 les premiers seront
accueillis d'autre part comme vous
l'avez rappelé michel denis
l'epide et la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse travaillent déjà ensemble à
la réinsertion de ces gènes qui ayant
plongé leur père ni leur peine
souhaitent s'engager dans un projet de
formation professionnelle pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons je suis
favorable le service citoyen ainsi
qu'aux diverses dispositions contenues
dans cette proposition de loi d'eric
ciotti
nous devons négliger aucune solution qui
puisse faire régresser la délinquance
kyi win 1 terrasse dans nombre de
lecteurs de nos quartiers dans nos vies
concernant la question préalable
c'est vrai je regrette que la commission
des lois se soit contenté de proposer au
sénat l'adoption d'une question
préalable
d'abord la question préalable et la
procédure qui considèrent qu'il est
inutile et dit libéré au fond vous
refusez par là même au sénat de pouvoir
jouer son rôle de réflexion sur un sujet
important
nous aurions pu amendé le texte il
enrichit vous refusez des données au
sénat la possibilité de le faire
vous auriez même pu proposer un autre
projet ou en contre projet qui réponde à
la question qui nous est posée
aujourd'hui quelles solutions proposons
aujourd'hui pour répondre à la
délinquance des mineurs
enfin et surtout je constate que vous ne
faites aucune proposition et je le
regrette vraiment pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons bien sûr je ne voterai pas la
question préalable
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est à monsieur yves détraigne
pour le groupe de l'union centriste et
républicaine
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois mme leblanc tentant
mais chers collègues
une fois n'est pas coutume je suis
tentée de commencer mon intervention par
une question que j'ai déjà été amené à
poser ces derniers mois qu'elle ait
lutté l'été réel de cette proposition
doit ou plutôt est ce qu'elle est
vraiment indispensable au vu du nombre
de textes dans le domaine de la justice
de la sécurité qui nous ont été soumis
ces derniers mois on est en droit de
s'interroger la délinquance des mineurs
est un problème très important il ne
s'agit pas ici minimiser cette
problématique bien au contraire il
s'agit de s'interroger sur la méthode
qui consiste à faire évoluer en
permanence des textes sur des sujets qui
nécessitent au contraire me semble-t-il
un travail et une réflexion de fond je
ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas rechercher
des solutions innovantes en matière de
lutte contre la délinquance des mineurs
mais est il raisonnable de procéder à
peu près tous les trois mois des
modifications de l'ordonnancé de 1945
déjà lors de l'examen du projet de loi
sur la participation des citoyens au
fonctionnement de la justice pénale et
le jugement des mineurs
je vais regretter l'abandon de facto du
code pénal des mineurs réforme
d'ensemble de cette matière qui avait
été annoncé en 2008
si je ne me trompe pas on nous propose
aujourd'hui la 33e modification de ce
texte fondateur qu'il ordonnance de 1945
et qui est devenu au fil des ans d'une
complexité telle quelle nuit à la clarté
la compréhension de notre droit
pourquoi abandonner une vraie réforme
d'ensemble sur un sujet de fond au
profit d'un énième rafistolage de l'
ordonnance de 1945
laissons le temps aux acteurs de ce
secteur de travailler et ne venons pas
en permanence tout bouleverser cette
réflexion sur le temps doit cependant
être complétée par une réflexion sur les
moyens financiers comme lors de l'
annonce des jurés populaires
pierre correctionnel alors que chacun
connaît le contexte budgétaire
extrêmement serré auquel le monde
judiciaire n'échappe pas on nous annonce
pour ce service citoyen le redéploiement
de 8 millions d'euros ne ferait on pas
mieux de renforcer les moyens existants
plutôt que de redéployer et 8 millions
pour la mise en oeuvre d'une mesure dont
l'efficacité n'est pas démontrée
car si la mesure que nous propose
monsieur ciotti peut apparaître
séduisante de premier abord on constate
qu'elle n'est pas sans inconvénients le
dispositif est assez simple on nous
propose une nouvelle mesure pénale
consistant l'exécution par le mineurs de
plus de 16 ans auteur d'une infraction
d'un contrat de services en
établissement public d'insertion de la
défense en epide
l'idée paraît de prime abord
intéressante mais le problème est de
savoir si cela a déjà été rappelé si les
epide ne vont pas être demain totalement
déstabilisés par l'arrivée de ces
mineurs délinquants
actuellement les epide sur des
structures qui fonctionnent bien
ce constat est partagé sur tous les
bancs on l'a entendu y compris de la
part de ceux qui les avaient dénoncés au
moment de leur création
mais peu importe l'important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde soit
d'accord sur le constat ces structures
sont utiles et fonctionne notamment en
matière de réinsertion pour la formation
professionnelle puisque 73% j'ai noté
que madame la rapporteur avait dit 40 à
50% tout à l'heure des jeunes qui vont
au bout du parcours sont insérés demain
ces centres devront accueillir des
mineurs délinquants contre 1 contre 1 de
fait à une décision de justice
cela risque de perturber les jeunes déjà
présents au sein des epide qui eux
intègrent ces établissements sur la base
du volontariat et de remettre en cause
leur attractivité leur rôle je sais bien
que le texte ne prévoit pas formellement
de contraintes pour le mineur délinquant
mais peut-on réellement parler de
volontariat quand la conclusion d'un
contrat de volontariat pour l'insertion
permet d'obtenir un abandon des
poursuites
un ajournement de la peine ou un sursis
comme notre rapporteur je m'interroge
donc sur la portée de ce qu'elle a
justement appelé un consentement sous
contrainte
c'est la critique majeure que l'on peut
faire à ce texte
le fait de mélanger des publics très
différents certains qui sont volontaires
pour pouvoir s'en sortir et d'autres à
qui l'on imposera une décision de
justice
la proposition de loi risque donc de
dénaturer la vocation initiale des epide
qui repose sur le volontariat
volontariat réel des jeunes en
difficulté de plus je m'interroge sur
l'adhésion des personnels concernés par
le dispositif
selon moi l'implication des acteurs de
terrain dans la définition et la mise en
oeuvre des décisions politiques est
indispensable à sa réussite
or les personnels des epide semblent
dubitatifs et inquiet face à cette
proposition
enfin il me semble inopportun de suscité
dans l'opinion publique dé confusion sur
le rôle des militaires dans notre
société leur rôle n'est pas de prendre
en charge la délinquance des mineurs
les militaires ne sont pas préparés à
encadrer des jeunes délinquants
pour conclure je tiens cependant à faire
une remarque sur la forme mon opinion
sur le texte en l'état vous l'avez
compris n'est pas favorable mais
devait-on s'arrêter là je ne le pense
pas
ce texte vous peut-être améliorer amendé
et des garanties complémentaires
auraient pu auraient dû être apportés
c'est notre rôle de parlementaire et
c'est à cette condition que le sénat
apporte une plus-value au travail de
l'assemblée nationale comme notre
collègue christian cointat l'a dit en
commission je regrette donc l'absence
d'amélioration possible du texte et
qu'avec la motion qui nous est annoncée
les sénateurs soit définitivement privé
de la possibilité de faire leur travail
je ne peux je ne pense pas que c'est de
cette manière qu'on peut revaloriser le
rôle du sénat
bien au contraire et je le regrette
je vous remercie chers collègues la
parole est maintenant à monsieur félix
desplan du groupe socialiste écologie
europe ecologie les verts
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai un collègue le problème
des mineurs délinquants est réelle il a
ses hauts lieux
il va devoir nous préoccuper chaque jour
un peu plus si la situation ici en
métropole
c'est aussi la situation dans les
outre-mers en guadeloupe d'ailleurs
avant la fin de l'année un congrès
spécifiques se penchera sur ce fait de
société
la création de ce en dépit d' n'a pas
été étendu aux départements d'outre-mer
cette structure n'existe donc pas dans
nos territoires
alors que le mal être de notre jeunesse
est patent partout est ce le fait de
négligences de nos gouvernants est ce le
coût de fonctionnement de ces centres
qui est en cause nous observons du reste
que sur le territoire métropolitain
le dispositif prévu n'est pas totalement
appliquée en effet si la loi du 24
novembre 2009 autorise les pid
accueillir des mineurs
dans les faits ce n'est pas le cas at on
pensé que le sm a le service militaire
adapté peut assurer à lui seul dans les
dom la prise en charge de nos jeunes en
difficulté de formation et d'insertion
professionnelle
rappelons que le sms est un organisme
militaire qui vient en aide aux jeunes
ultramarins en difficulté basé sur le
volontariat
ceci passe par une formation humaine
comportementale scolaire et
professionnelle pour les amener vers
l'insertion dans la vie active civile
soit par le biais de contrats d'abord
soit par l'entrée en formation
professionnelle certifiante toutefois
toutefois
seul un candidat sur 6 en moyenne est
actuellement accepté au sein de cette
structure
il s'agit donc le système sélectif qui
s'adresse aux jeunes qui bien qu'en
difficulté présente déjà un bon
potentiel d'insertion une montée en
puissance est prévu puisqu'il est
envisagée le doubler à l'horizon 2014 le
nombre de bénéficiaires pour la porter à
six mille
il ne faut pas cependant que cela se
fasse au détriment de la durée de la
formation donnée et de sa qualité
les résultats peuvent être considérés
comme très encourageant avec un taux
d'insertion qui varie de 64 ap le cap et
les poussant selon les départements
le cema en coopération avec l'agencé de
l'outre-mer pour la mobilité ladom
envisage une solution d'insertion en
france métropolitaine de 1200 jeunes
volontaires aux domiens à l'horizon 2012
il est à craindre toutefois que éloignés
de leurs centres d'intérêt et de leurs
proches
le bilan de réussite pour ces jeunes
soient moins d'eau mais là aussi sont
seulement conservé les jeunes adultes de
18 à 25 ans en situation d'échec
les mineurs ne le sont pas quant aux
mineurs délinquants
il n'existe pour eux aucune solution
véritable cette délinquance juvénile et
en pourcentage ne les ai pas aux tentes
dans les territoires ultramarins qui est
le tout gamin qui si comme le révèlent
les chiffres qui suivent la part des
mineurs mis en cause pour les actifs
volontaires à l'intégrité physique est
de 18 3% dans les dom au maillot et de
21 5,5 1% en métropole
la part des mineurs dans le total des
mises en cause pour les atteintes aux
biens et de 28 53% dans les dom et de 33
76 % en métropole mais on assiste
aujourd'hui et les statistiques les plus
récentes en atteste à une forte
croissance des comportements
répréhensibles dans une heure
augmentation de la part des mineurs mis
en cause pour les avis en 2010 + 0 97
dans les dom contre + 0.7 à métropole
augmentation plus importante encore de
la part des mineurs pour les arabes et
en 2010 +1 point 66 dans les dom contre
0.12 à métropole
peut-on rester les bras croisés face à
ces phénomènes
peut-on faire semblant de prendre à bras
le corps la situation par de l'affichage
politique en guadeloupe ont recours aux
travaux d'intérêt général en moyenne
pour l'année en cours une vingtaine par
mois alternative à l'incarcération censé
éviter la récidive est destiné à
organiser la réception le tj est
prononcée à l'encontre des majeurs mais
aussi des mineurs à titre de peine
principale ou en complément d'une peine
de prison avec sursis
il s'agit de travail non rémunéré au
sein d'une association d'une
collectivité publique d'un établissement
public ou d'une personne morale de droit
privé chargées d'une mission de service
public
il est à noter que la dimension
d'intérêt général du travail ne va pas
de soi pour l'adolescent le choix du
lieu notamment apparaît important
par rapport à l'objectif visé en
guadeloupe
à l'instar des autres départements
ultramarins les carrosses de mises en
causes sont multiples mécanismes de mise
en oeuvre
pardon sont multiples en voici
quelques-unes nombreuses dérives à cause
du non suivi réel de ces jeunes
orientation vers un lieu d'exécution
sans accompagnement à oublier à me sens
2001 systématique à la fin de la période
de prise en charge le lieu d'exécution
ne feront pas le personnel encadrant
capable d'intervenir sur le plan
éducatif et social
parmi ces adolescents bénéficiaires des
tg nombreux sont les consommateurs de
drogues qui récidive par la suite des
améliorations à ses tiges et peuvent
éprouver il faut y mettre de la volonté
certes mais aussi les moyens par rapport
avec les objectifs visés à côté de cela
la mise en place de centre epide ne
serait pas de trop
en outre-mer je veux rappeler ici que le
chômage des jeunes actifs de 15 à 25 ans
y est tout particulièrement préoccupant
puisqu'il a été soi se poussant dans
plusieurs départements
les sorties pitt serait donc les
bienvenues pour accueillir tous ces
jeunes en situation de détresse sociale
mais il ne saurait constituer une
véritable alternative à l'exception des
mineurs délinquants
il convient de poursuivre la réflexion
pour proposer d'autres solutions data
vraiment bien plus adapté je vous
remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur
avant de passer la parole à monsieur
louis
j'informe le sénat que la liste des
candidats présentés par les groupes pour
la désignation de six membres
supplémentaires de la mission commune
d'information sur les conséquences pour
les collectivités territoriales l'état
et les entreprises de la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle et son
remplacement par la contribution
économique territoriale a été affichée à
16 heures en application de l'article 8
alinéa 3 à 11 de notre règlement elle
sera donc fakty ratifié à 18 heures si
la présidence ne reçoit pas d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
maintenant à monsieur louis
membres du groupe ump
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je souhaiterais évoqué
trois points d'abord un état des lieux
il y à motifs effectivement de s'en
préoccuper
la proposition de notre excellent
collègue eric ciotti que nous devons
examiner aujourd'hui au sénat et d'une
actualité
malheureusement criante et vise à
instaurer un service citoyen pour les
mineurs délinquants
il est vrai que le phénomène de la
délinquance des mineurs connaît depuis
plusieurs années une augmentation entre
1977 et 1992 chers collègues les faits
de délinquance impliquant les mineurs
sont passés de 82000 à 98 mille par an
soit une augmentation de 20,4 % entre
2004 et 2009 l'augmentation même moindre
persiste à hauteur de 16% avec 214 mille
faits recensés en 2009
cette évolution mes chers collègues
n'est pas spécifique à la france
nos voisins européens sont confrontés à
la même situation
mais ce n'est pas une raison suffisante
pour ne rien faire
le gouvernement a réagi monsieur le
garde des sceaux
voilà notre différence avec vous vous
réfléchissez vous l'avez dit madame le
rapporteur nous nous agissons
et madame le rapporteur madame le
rapporteur madame le rapporteur je
voulais vous rassurer nous ne cacherons
rien depuis 2002 notre législation a
donc évolué pour mieux appréhender les
différents aspects de cette délinquance
de nouveaux établissements éducatifs ont
été ouverts de nouveaux moyens de
prévention ont été adoptés ainsi la loi
du 9 septembre 2002 a instauré les
centres éducatifs fermés
de même la loi du 5 mars 2007 dite loi
sur la prévention de la délinquance a
introduit de nombreux dispositifs de
prévention
cependant comme l'a excellemment vie ma
précédente colette colette eu dix
énigmes
cependant malgré ces évolutions
législatives
il apparaît qu'entre la prison et la rue
il n'ya pas suffisamment d'alternatives
c'est l'objet précisément madame le
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
d'eric ciotti que je soutiens pleinement
avait voilà la différence et dont je me
félicite
c'est le deuxième point que je souhaite
maintenant évoquer cette ppl vise en
effet à compléter les structures
existantes en proposant un service
citoyen pour mineurs délinquants
vous savez mes chers collègues que cette
mesure est plébiscité par le concitoyen
par delà les clivages politiques que
vous l'avez vous même dit tout à l'heure
ainsi selon un sondage ifop effectué le
10 juin 2011 93% d'entre eux de nos
concitoyens sont favorables à
l'instauration d'un service civique pour
les mineurs délinquants 97 97 % à droite
ce qui est bien normal et 90% madame le
rapporteur à gauche mais aussi mes chers
collègues
soyons à la hauteur de ce qu'attendent
de nous les français
encore une fois encore une fois face à
cette délinquance ne resteront pas
inertes agissons et je trouve les je
trouve et jeudi pour le moins surprenant
original et pour tout dire bien
contradictoire de votre part à gauche de
soutenir à tout bout de champ la
démocratie représentative et de refuser
ici au sénat d'engager une discussion
sur le fond deere deere deere d'envoyer
à la tribune j'allais dire au front pas
moins de onze orateurs dont le
rapporteur pour esquiver le débat
vous ne pouviez pas chers collègues vous
ne pouviez pas faire un meilleur hommage
à ce texte
ce texte crée ce chaînon manquant au
travers de la mise en place d'un service
citoyen ce service citoyen s'appuiera
sur l'apport que peuvent avoir les
valeurs militaires en matière
d'insertion de jeunes en difficulté et
sur le dispositif défense deuxième
chance
mis en oeuvre depuis 2005 dans les
centres de l'établissement public
d'insertion de la défense
en effet face à une population de
mineurs délinquants en manque de repères
les valeurs militaires est tout
simplement civique peuvent constituer
une réponse adaptée
le savoir-faire des armées en matière
d'insertion des jeunes en difficulté
vous l'avez dit les uns et les autres
s'est exprimé positivement par le passé
dans le cadre du service militaire
obligatoire ainsi que dans celui des
jeunes en équipes de travail qu'avait
initié l'amiral brac de la perrière
il s'exprime comme l'a dit l'orateur
précédent et s'exprime aujourd'hui
encore au travers du service militaire
adapté en outre-mer par ailleurs le
contrat de service un établissement
public d'insertion de la défense
s'appliquera dans un cadre bien précis
rappelons le il sera établi par un
magistrat de plus cette mesure ne
s'adressera cas des mineurs âgés de plus
de 16 ans ayant exprimé cet important
mort
porter leurs consentements en suivre une
telle mesure
le volontariat j insiste et ne vous en
déplaise est au coeur du dispositif
je rappelle que les trois objectifs du
contrat de service citoyen sont
particulièrement bienvenus s'ils ont de
bien dépasser les clivages idéologiques
démagogique ou tout simplement
politiciens tout d'abord pour ces jeunes
une mise à niveau en français
orthographe mathématiques
ensuite une formation civique et
comportementale
enfin une pré formation professionnelle
qualifiante
je rappelle que le taux d'insertion sur
le marché du travail des jeunes qui
suivent le parcours actuellement dans
les epide et de plus de 70%
c'est un résultat chers collègues des
plus enviables qui confirme donc la
justesse de la ppl qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui et on refuserait cette
nouvelle chance pour ces jeunes c'est
incompréhensible
l'accueil des mineurs dans ces centres
constituera une véritable alternative
crédible et efficace à l'incarcération
ou au placement en centre éducatif fermé
l'objectif à travers la mesure proposée
est également de transmettre à ces
jeunes en rupture des notions quelque
peu oublié madame telles que la
citoyenneté le respect de la règle et de
l'autorité
le sens de l'effort et du mérite qu'il
pourrait parmi nous ne pas être d'accord
qui c'est si vrai madame que cette
proposition de loi a été adopté en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
le 12 octobre et je ne peux que me
réjouir aussi aussi aussi j'ai été très
surpris que la commission des lois du
sénat et adopter une question préalable
qui refusent au sénat au lieu du débat
démocratique
sa raison d'être
le changement de majorité commencent ce
mal aussi
aussi face à une situation qui s'aggrave
chaque jour nous le savons tous face à
une augmentation des actes de
délinquance et donc du nombre de
victimes mais qui y pense c'est
peut-être là chers collègues
c'est peut-être là chers collègues
michel qu'est le scandale la réponse
n'est donc pas dans l'obstruction où
l'attentisme
au contraire il nous faut agir c'est
notre devoir c'est notre devoir chers
collègues même même votre précédent
candidat à la présidentielle
madame ségolène royal vous ya invité
aussi ça sera mon troisième point face à
des arguments pas toujours justifiées à
mes yeux je souhaiterais mes chers
collègues opposés
certaines vérités tout d'abord les
magistrats elle est responsable de
l'epide ont bien évidemment été
entendues dans le cadre de l'élaboration
de la proposition de loi eric ciotti
j'ai vérifié auprès de lui a eu
l'occasion vous le savez parfaitement
d'auditionner plusieurs représentants et
au plus haut niveau
des syndicats de magistrats quant aux
professionnels ce dispositif a été mis
en place avec les services de l'epide
c'est à dire les spécialistes du dossier
par ailleurs contrairement à ce que
certains ont dit ici il n'existe aucun
risque de déstabilisation des epide par
le mélange d'une population de mineurs
délinquants avec une population de
majeurs volontaire en effet bien qu
étant volontaire je dis bien la moitié
la moitié des jeunes qui se trouvent
dans les epide ont déjà été confrontés à
la justice
et bon nombre d'entre eux ont déjà connu
la prison
cette proposition de loi vise à
instaurer un service citoyen pour les
mineurs délinquants au sein des epide
n'altèrera donc d'aucune manière la
stabilité de ces centres je regrette je
re de devoir constater que les arguments
de la gauche
de fond ils sont constitutifs d'un
esprit partisan d'un camp contre l'autre
alors que seul l'intérêt des mineurs
délinquants et de la société doit être
recherchée eric eric ciotti a eu le
courage politique monsieur le président
et la volonté de faire une proposition
concrète et pragmatique et je remercie
monsieur le garde des sceaux de défendre
cette ppl il faut chers collègues
soutenir cette démarche pleine de bon
sens et d' arrêter d'opposer au principe
de réalité
les critères d'une idéologie dépassée
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi en
conclusion je m'opposerai à cette
question préalable inopportune et
contre-productive
nous pensons au contraire que cette
proposition de loi doit pouvoir être
mises en oeuvre dans les meilleurs
délais dans l'intérêt des jeunes qui en
bénéficieront mais aussi dans l'intérêt
de la sécurité de nos concitoyens et je
le rappelle de la société en général
plutôt que d'organiser un combat à
retardement faisons chers collègues
oeuvre utile et efficace auprès de ces
jeunes en rupture les français vous en
seront reconnaissants
je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur et
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
à madame muguette dini pour le groupe
union peau de l'union centriste et
républicaine
ça va pas être facile hein de passer
derrière monsieur
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux chers collègues lorsque les
parents s'habitue à laisser faire leurs
enfants lorsque les enfants ne tiennent
plus compte de leurs paroles lorsque les
maîtres tremblent devant leurs élèves
lorsque finalement les jeunes méprisent
les lois parce qu'ils ne reconnaissent
plus au dessus d'eux l'autorité de rien
ni de personne
alors c'est en toute justesse le début
de la tyrannie
oui la jeunesse n'a que du mépris pour
ceux de ses maîtres qui s'abaisse à la
suivre au lieu de la guider cette
analyse est celle de platon en 427 avant
jésus-christ elle est saisissante de
vérité est toujours actuelle au travers
de cette proposition de loi monsieur le
garde des sceaux je vois essentiellement
l'aveu le constat d'un double échec de
notre mission éducative
l'éducation est l'un des principaux
problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui à
notre pays
ce mineur adolescents délinquants est un
humain adulte en devenir envers lequel
le monde adulte un devoir d'éducation
j'adhère pleinement à la philosophie qui
a inspiré l'ordonance du 2 février 45
celle selon laquelle la cause première
du basculement du mineurs dans la
délinquance réside dans le déficit
d'éducation je crois monsieur le
ministre que cette philosophie se
dessine aussi derrière cette proposition
de loi
l'urgence première est de remobiliser
les parents sur le devoir d'éduquer la
conduite d'une politique d'appui à la
parentalité est en effet un enjeu
important pour notre société
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
depuis 40 ans la famille s'est
profondément transformé surtout -
institutionnalisée que par le passé la
vie familiale suscite davantage de
questionnements et de doutes de la part
des parents les familles doivent donc
être épaulé tout au long de leur
existence
ce soutien à la parentalité par des
dispositifs d'action publique est
intégrée au périmètre des politiques
familiales
puis la fin des années 1990 il doit
absolument se poursuivre en s'amplifiant
et il est indispensable d'augmenter les
crédits alloués à l'accompagnement des
familles dans leur rôle parental
autre échec celui de notre école
aujourd'hui source de dévalorisation et
d'inégalités elle est aussi génératrices
de violence
notre système scolaire ne transmet plus
les valeurs qui ont assuré la cohésion
sociale de notre pays ainsi que la
construction individuelle de chacun
cette proposition se veut être une
réponse à cet échec de l'éducatif et je
me pose les mêmes questions que beaucoup
de nos collègues mais je ne vous rejoint
pas madame la rapporteure quand vous
indiquer de façon très expéditive que ce
texte est un texte de circonstance dont
il n'y a rien à tirer
je souhaite insister sur l'encadrement
militaire si critiqué ticket pardon je
serais pour ma part plus mesuré et je
vais rejoindre les propos de notre
collègue félix desplan
en avril dernier j'ai conduit une
délégation de notre commission des
affaires sociales en mission d'étude en
martinique et en guyane
lors de notre séjour en martinique nous
avons visité durant toute une matinée
le régiment du service militaire adapté
le sm à présent dans la quasi-totalité
des collectivités d'outre-mer assure
dans un environnement exclusivement
militaire une formation professionnelle
à de jeunes ultramarins volontaires en
difficulté il contribue également par le
biais de chantiers d'application au
développement économique des
collectivités d'outre-mer ainsi qu'à la
protection civile notamment lors des
catastrophes naturelles
l' engagement à servir dans le schéma
est fondé sur le volontariat et c'est
vrai il existe une procédure de
sélection afin de vérifier notamment que
le candidat n'a pas eu de démêlés trop
lourde avec la justice
son objectif est d'aider un jeune en
difficulté
à recevoir une formation de base afin de
lui permettre ensuite d'obtenir un
diplôme de trouver un emploi ce
dispositif constitue pour ce profil de
jeune
le chaînon manquant entre la formation
initiale et la vie professionnelle
au total c'est plus de 120 mille jeunes
qui sont passés sur nos territoires par
le sm a depuis sa création en 1961
aujourd'hui 37 métiers sont proposés il
est important de souligner que le sm a
met l'accent sur le comportement et les
règles de vie à respecter en société la
formation globale proposée par le sm a
est ainsi fondée sur la rupture que
suppose l'acte d'engagement et la vie en
internat dans une enceinte militaire
le sm a dispose actuellement d'environ
700 personnels d'encadrement en majorité
des militaires détachés par le ministère
de la défense ainsi que d'un état major
pour tous les membres de notre mission
ce fut une vraie découverte
nous avons tous reconnu l'incontestable
succès de ce dispositif
cette paire cette visite a permis sans
nul doute de dédiaboliser l'encadrement
militaire des jeunes en rupture sociale
j'adhère donc à cette idée que
l'encadrement militaire peut être une
bonne chose
la question qui se pose ici est de deux
ordres
faut-il confier une partie de
l'enseignement professionnel pas
seulement destiné à des délinquants à
des militaires manifestement plus
performant que l'éducation nationale je
ne rappellerai pas les 160 160 mille
jeunes qui sortent sans formation est il
sain de mélanger dans les epide des
jeunes volontaires non délinquants avec
des jeunes délinquants qui ont comme
seule alternative à l'incarcération
ce dispositif d'encadrement militaire je
n'insisterai pas beaucoup de mes
collègues ont évoqué cette vraie
question
cette juxtaposition paraît bien
dangereuse ne vaudrait-il mieux pas
créer sur le modèle des epide des
structures uniquement consacrée aux
jeunes délinquants
sans doute un examen approfondi de ce
texte et l'adoption d'amendements dans
ce sens aurait permis à la majorité de
notre groupe de l'adopter et je ne peux
que regretter la décision de la
commission des lois de rejeter cette
proposition de loi est de proposer au
sénat d'adopter la question préalable
je vous remercie je vous remercie madame
la sénatrice
la parole est à madame esther benbassa
du groupe socialiste europe écologie les
verts
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission madame l'europe
la rapporteure mes chers collègues sous
prétexe de compléter les solutions
offertes à la justice est de trouver des
remèdes pour les jeunes en manque de
repères et en rupture sociale
la proposition de loi qui nous est
soumise à la va vite n'est constituée
que de mesures est cosmétique et
inefficaces sur la méthode tout d'abord
un tel chantier législatives auraient dû
être entrepris dans le respect du débat
parlementaire
mais le gouvernement a fait le choix
d'une procédure accélérée
c'est dans une fois encore à l'urgence
et à l'électoralisme
sur le fond je consacrerai l'essentiel
de mon intervention aux cinq premiers
articles du texte
madame catherine tasca ayant
excellemment prêter de l'ajout de
dernière minute d'un article 6 je
partage
quand en moi la position de l'autre la
porter et des magies cela sur les
difficultés engendrées un article 6 les
sénatrices et sénateurs écologistes
rejette fermement cette atteinte faite à
la nécessité de préserver la continuité
du suivi éducatif des mineurs exigences
constitutionnelles qui aurait dû être
prise en compte dans le cadre d'une
réflexion globale et approfondie
mais outre cette grève de l'article 6
qui ne prend pas le reste de la
proposition est également contestable à
plus d'un titre
en premier lieu les mesures contenues
dans les cinq premiers articles de la
proposition comporte de nombreuses
confusions et suscite l'incompréhension
y compris chez les professionnels du
droit
ainsi la présente proposition de loi ne
précise pas si les mesures qui
le contient s'applique aux
primo-délinquants aux mineurs
récidivistes ou multirécidiviste
heureusement que monsieur le ministre
vient de nous dire que les
multirécidivistes ne sont pas concernés
on ignore également si la qualification
pénale des infractions délit ou crime
sera ou non plus en compte cette
confusion étape est accentuée par le
caractère militaire du dispositif en
effet l'on sait que les epide sont
composés à 42% d'anciens militaires et
que le ministère de la défense a fourni
à l'origine les terrains et les
bâtiments
le rapport nous indique nous indique
également que ce même ministère sera
sollicité financièrement à hauteur de 2
millions d'euros
si les mesures contenues dans ce texte
finissent par être voté ce dont je doute
tellement ce tête semble a raison ce à
l'unanimité contre lui
dès lors même si les epide sont conçus
comme des établissements civile
d'enseignement et d'internât l'ambiguïté
persistent comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de l'indiquer devant notre commission
des lois les sénatrices sellette
écologie sont hostiles à la
militarisation de l'insertion des
mineurs délinquants
ben on verra autre confusion entretenu
autre confusion entretenue par ce test
la référence à un contrôle et c'est à la
volonté des jeunes pour l'entrée dans le
dispositif alors que dans le même temps
nous sommes face à une mesure de
contrainte imposée par l'institution
judiciaire
il s'agit en réalité bien d'une
obligation puisque ce service est prévue
à l'article 1er de la proposition de loi
comme modalité de la composition pénale
ainsi si le procureur de la république
propose un jeune l'exécution d'un
service citoyen il n'aura in fine est
pas le choix soit l'action publique
s'éteint et l'emprunt epide
soit il est poursuivi pénalement le même
raisonnement est applicable par analogie
à l'article 2 du texte relatif à
l'accomplissement du service à l'epide
dans le cadre de l' ajournement de
belles ou à l'article 3 qui lui concerne
le sursis avec mise à l'épreuve dans ces
deux autres hypothèses le caractère
volontaire du dispositif demeure aussi
purement théorique
au delà c'est l'esprit même de ce
nouveau texte répressif liberticide et
sécuritaire que les sénatrices et
sénateurs écologistes contestent
fermement
il s'agit ici encore commun et
coutumières venues certains droits
populaires de chercher à flirter avec
l'électorat de l'extrême droite en
faisant des effet d'annonce
je vais vous citer monsieur ciotti je
vais vous citer monsieur ciotti qui dit
lui même en fermant ces jeunes pour
protéger la société
en pratique ces mesures ne concerneront
pourtant qu'une poignée de jeunes et ne
règleront évidemment pas les problèmes
liés à la délinquance des mineurs
en effet la délinquance juvénile
apparaît comme une problématique ancien
des gis presque entièrement par l'
ordonnance de février 1945 qui repose
sur une dichotomie en justice des
mineurs et justice des majeurs et dont
l'article 2 donne aux mesures éducatives
la primauté sur les sanctions monsieur
or la proposition de loi de monsieur
ciotti sincère aux la proposition de loi
de monsieur ciotti s'insère dans une
série de lois votées précédemment tel
ben en perben 2 l'option puis la loppsi
2 et enfin la loi du 11 août 2011
relative aux jurés populaires et à la
justice des mineurs
toutes mettent l'accent sur la réponse
pénale dans un contexte où la rhétorique
sécuritaire prime sur la recherche de
solutions viables aux mots et aux crises
économiques successives dont souffle
notre société les mesures préconisées
par ce projet de loi risque
à nous de déstabiliser le fonctionnement
des epide qui ne sont pas adaptés à
l'accueil de mineurs délinquants
il serait préjudiciable de bouleverser
la dynamique de ces structures qui
fonctionnent bien pour le moment
pourrait faire entrer une toute petite
poignée de mineurs délinquants
lorsque 40000 bénéficient déjà en milieu
ouvert de la palette de dispositifs de
prise en charge les sénateurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs écologistes le
jette donc en bloc
la philosophie de ce texte
et plaide en faveur de solutions de
prévention ou de mesures adaptées à
l'âge et aux situations des intéressés
et en particulier des mesures éducatives
ou de placement en milieu ouvert
favorisons l'a20 session des jeunes
concernés impliquant tous les acteurs
famille école éducateurs enfin je
terminerai en rappelant le coût
exorbitant d'un tel dispositif alors que
le budget consacré actuellement à la
formation d'un jeune majeur dans ces
établissements est en moyenne de 32
mille euros par mineur et en 2000 euros
le rapport nous indique qu'il le rapport
sur les epide nous indique qu'il
s'élèvera à 50 mille euros par mineur
délinquant dans cette période de crise
où le budget de la justice peine déjà à
obtenir les fonds qui lui permettrait de
fonctionner au mieux
pensez vous sincèrement que ces
nouvelles dépenses soit nécessaire pour
toutes ces raisons les sénatrices et
sénateurs écologie sont évidemment
hostile à cette proposition de loi qui a
d'ailleurs été rejetée par notre
commission des lois ainsi nous
soutiendrons la motion de procédure et
voteront donc pour la question préalable
merci pour votre attention merci madame
la sénatrice
la parole est maintenant monsieur alain
néri pour le groupe socialiste europe
écologie les verts
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
oui la délinquance des mineurs est un
problème réel et important mais qui ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
même s'il est particulièrement
d'actualité en effet dès 1945
le gouvernement de la libération sans
était préoccupé en mettant en oeuvre
leur bonheur de protection de l'enfance
en danger
d'ailleurs la description de l'enfant
sondage était clair enfants en danger
tout enfant dont la moralité la santé
l'éducation sont compromises un tel
sujet nécessitent à l'évidence un projet
ambitieux et réfléchie pour les enfants
et adolescents en difficulté or la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
est avant tout un texte d'affichage
c'est pourquoi je conteste et réfute
l'opportunité et le contenu de ce texte
pourquoi proposer une nouvelle réforme
de l'honneur de l'ordonance 2,45 alors
que vous affirmez monsieur le ministre
qu'un code de la justice pénale des
mineurs est quasiment achevée il est
donc parfaitement illogique et
inopportun de faire de nouvelles
modifications qui ne pourront que nuire
à la lisibilité et à la cohérence de
l'ordonance sur le fond votre
proposition est inutile en effet
l'article 10 ordonnance de 45 permet
déjà le placement de mineurs dans des
établissements et dans des institutions
d'éducation de formation professionnelle
ou de soins de l'état ou d'une
administration publique habilité pour
toutes ces raisons il n'y a pas lieu de
créer un nouveau dispositif législatif
si ce n'est pour faire du spectaculaire
et un effet d'annonce à travers un texte
de circonstance
à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
à l'origine les epide avait pour
vocation d'assurer l'insertion
professionnelle et sociale de jeunes en
difficulté scolaire sans qualification
professionnelle ni emploi en risque de
marginalisation
mais volontaires pour s'engager dans un
projet éducatif global c'est-à-dire
une véritable école de la deuxième
chance votre texte propose de mêler à
ces jeunes volontaires de jeunes
délinquants qui doivent choisir entre
prison epide vous transformer une
structure d'insertion en structure de
sanctions en alternative à l'enfermement
les jeunes accueillis étant différent
l' approche pédagogique ne peut être la
même il faut en effet individualiser les
parcours d'éducation et de formation
pour être efficace ce n'est pas votre
nouvelles modifications des ordonnances
de 45 qui remplacera l'absence
d'éducateur en milieu ouvert présent
intervenir dès le début de la
déscolarisation ou des difficultés
d'autorité parentale ni l'absence de
structures de rééducation adaptée
monsieur le ministre pour mettre en
place une véritable politique de
prévention il faut radicalement changer
les orientations de votre politique en
direction des services de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
depuis trois ans vous avez supprimer 400
postes de pgi votre budget 2011 à lui
seul près à organiser la disparition de
117 postes
quant à votre budget 2012 il semble
poursuivre sur cette lancée et parade
actuellement les crédits des epide sont
prévues en d'émission de 5 millions
d'euros passant de 85 à 80 millions de
plus cerise sur le gâteau le directeur
de l'epide à qui vous aviez reconnu
beaucoup de mérite vient d'être
remerciée du jour au lendemain sans
explication mais peut-être monsieur le
ministre
allez vous enfin nous en donner une en
réalité il est urgent de redonner les
moyens la pjj d'exercer sa mission car
sans nier les qualités des uns et des
autres rappelez vous monsieur le
ministre ce vieux principe d'efficacité
à chacun son métier s'agissant de la
jeunesse est plus particulier des jeunes
en difficulté on ne peut se satisfaire
de texte de circonstance voire de
bricolage en tout genre organisé une
remise à plat
total de ce texte ordonné conduisait une
étude d'impact sérieuses qui dresse un
bilan des besoins humains et financiers
que requiert un sujet d'une telle
importance
donnons nous les moyens de développer
des politiques de prévention qui
éviterait de voir gâcher des vies de
trop nombreux jeunes citoyens et y de
plus par ces temps de crise financière
générerait de grandes économies pour
l'état et donnerait une nouvelle chance
une nouvelle espérance pour de nombreux
jeunes donnons aussi à la justice les
moyens de faire appliquer rapidement ses
décisions au lieu de la critique est
injustement ainsi ensemble nous
retrouverons le chemin de la cohésion
nationale
si le voeu que je formule avec les
sénateurs socialistes et sénatrices
socialistes
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole est
maintenant à madame michelle meunier du
groupe socialiste europe écologie les
verts est rattachée
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ce président de l'acq lotion
madame la rapporteure permettez moi
d'intervenir en tant que membre de la
commission des affaires sociales et avec
mon expérience de vice-présidente en
france famille au conseil général de
loire atlantique
en effet la question de la justice des
mineurs se situe à l'articulation des
politiques de protection de l'enfance et
de la politique pénale
jusqu'à ces dernières années l'éducatif
et est prioritaire sur le répressif mais
les dispositifs successifs votée par les
gouvernements de droite ont modifié
gravement cet équilibre et la mesure que
vous proposez aujourd'hui vient encore
renforcer l'arsenal des mesures
répressives qui laisserait penser que la
fermeté suffit à tout régler que
d'illusions sans faire d'angélisme
personne n'a oublié le grand progrès
humain de l' ordonnance de 1945 en
faveur de l'accompagnement éducatif des
mineurs qui a permis au plus grand
nombre d'entre eux de se construire un
avenir
on peut trébucher à un moment de son
enfance ou de sa jeunesse et se
redresser
d'autant que le respect de la règle fait
partie du processus éducatif et ne s'y
oppose pas comme on l'entend encore trop
souvent sur les bancs de la droite et
monsieur en a fait une petite
démonstration tout de suite
il est plus que temps de se confronter
aux réalités objectives de la
délinquance des mineurs et des majeurs
afin de rechercher des solutions
concrètes adaptées et sur mesure et d'en
mesurer les effets réels les faits
délictueux sont le fait de tous les âges
de toutes les classes sociales de tous
les territoires
même s'il ne fait aucun doute que la
précarité la pauvreté et la misère
sociale peuvent augmenter les risques du
moins les risques d'être repérés et
pénalisé comme cela a été récemment
rappelé à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale du refus de la misère mais
surtout force est de constater de par
mon expérience d'élu local également que
de nombreux pour ne pas dire la grande
majorité des auteurs ont été
antérieurement des victimes et
particulièrement dans leur enfance
il s'agit le plus souvent de violences
intrafamiliales de violences sexuelles
d'inceste et comment ne pas s'interroger
à une époque où les victimes s'expriment
et que de nombreuses études sérieuses
démontrent sur le lien entre la
situation subie à un moment donné et un
passage à l'acte délictueux il nous faut
renforcer les interventions précoces
auprès des victimes mais aussi agir de
manière préventive car c'est en à ce
moment de la vie que l'on peut encore
redonner confiance en l'être humain en
la justice et permettent de poursuivre
son chemin en sachant que ce que l'on a
subi ou ce que l'on a vu n'était ni
normal ni acceptable et c'est là en
respectant l'enfant le jeune où la jeune
victime qu'on instaure une relation de
confiance et de respect mutuel
car le respect ne s'impose pas par la
force contrairement à ce que l'on
voudrait nous faire croire
et c'est tout le rôle de la protection
de l'enfance je veux aussi souligner le
travail remarquable par les
professionnels des conseils généraux du
sang du sang 19 ans lien bien sûr avec
les policiers les gendarmes les
magistrats et les associations
habilitées pour aider les enfants
cabossés par la vie à reconstruire leur
avenir
et les résultats sont très positifs même
si bien sûr il y a toujours des progrès
qui restent à faire de nombreux exemples
nous montre qu'il faut toujours garder
confiance en nos jeunes et leur faire
savoir
une autre donne paraît importante à
regarder en face c'est la dimension
sexuée de la délinquance 96% des
personnes incarcérées sont des hommes
pour des faits exercer dans leur très
grande majorité à l'encontre des femmes
ou d'enfants
comment peut-on ignorer la relation
entre cette suite à cette situation
objective est le fondement de notre
société qui accepte encore trop la
domination masculine et qui ne leur
offre pas l'occasion d'interroger cette
toute puissance
nous aurons fait de grands progrès dans
notre fonctionnement social
lorsque nous accepterons de regarder et
d'analyser nos rapports sociaux de sexe
je veux également ici parlé de méthodes
car celle que l'on nous propose est d'un
autre âge c'est dépassé comme vous le
savez mon département de loire
atlantique a été particulièrement
éprouvée ces dernières années par des
faits d'une extrême gravité
je pense à marine le bo nazairienne
enceinte de 7 mois tuée par son conjoint
mais je pense aussi à agnès dupont de
ligonnès et ses quatre enfants tué
méthodiquement et dont les soupçons
pèsent lourdement sur le père est le
mari mais je pense évidemment à laëtitia
tuée sauvagement et à sa soeur jessica
violée par son assistant familial
pourquoi est-ce que je rappelle ces
faits parce que ces drames ont déclenché
la mobilisation de l'ensemble des
professionnels de la justice de nantes
qui a entraîné ensuite la mobilisation
nationale jusqu alors inédite
et que nous ont dit ces professionnels
que j'ai rencontré à plusieurs reprises
qu'il reste fortement motivés par leur
mission auprès des jeunes en difficulté
et des jeunes délinquants qu'ils
demandent des moyens d'exercer leur
mission en conformité avec la loi et
qu'ils souhaitent être associés à la
construction des réponses pénales
ce n'est pas autre chose que demandent
également les avocats réunis cette fin
de semaine dernière pour l'heure à
nantes pour leur convention nationale
votre méthode d'imposer des réponses
toutes faites n'a donc aucune chance de
succès il nous faut au contraire
écoutez ces professionnels de la justice
pour espérer construire ensemble des
réponses pertinentes
il nous faut aussi associer les familles
et les jeunes eux mêmes à la recherche
de réponses car ni les familles ni les
jeunes ne se satisfont de l'échec social
mais rien ne se fera sans moyens car
l'éducation est un investissement sûr
l'avenir et c'est là je pense notre
grande différence avec votre
gouvernement qui ne mise que sur des
solutions de court terme excessive et
dur pour les faibles les désengagements
successifs financier de l'état ampute
les démarches d'accompagnement éducatif
et démarche d'accompagnement et de
prévention en faveur des mineurs et des
jeunes majeurs rencontrant des
difficultés
la liste est longue je ne peux le faire
mais ici je ne cite que ce sur quoi le
sujet nous mène aujourd'hui c'est à dire
la diminution des moyens de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse qui
a entraîné au fil des années des reports
de charges vers les départements déjà
contraint dans leur budget certes je ne
nie pas la nécessité d'inventer de
nouvelles réponses à la délinquance de
certains jeunes
mais votre proposition est tellement
pleine d'ambiguïtés et de sous-entendus
tout en visant des effectifs tellement
insignifiant que je ne peut craindre au
niveau de vos réelles intentions avec
les jeunes monsieur le ministre il faut
avoir un discours particulièrement clair
alors je pense que la proposition que
vous nous faites aujourd'hui d'inscrire
quelques jeunes délinquants dans un
dispositif coercitif
à forte culture militaire risque de
s'ajouter au catalogue des mesures
coûteuses et inefficaces voire
contre-productive et je vous propose de
réorienter les financements envisagés
vers les dispositifs de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse qui en a grand
besoin et je vous en remercie
je vous remercie madame la sénatrice et
chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur michel mercier
ministre de la justice et garde des
sceaux
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
bien elle le sentiment que répondront
pas répondre ne changera pas la volonté
de la majorité du sénat de ne pas
débattre mais madame le rapporteur je
n'osais pas interrompu si vous vouliez
bien essayé de faire la même chose ce
serait déjà pas mal
moi je voudrais simplement dire une
chose
je voudrais simplement dire deux ou
trois beaux deux ou trois mois tout
d'abord nous rapportons en vous
entendant j'ai pris peur
pour une raison simple c'est que dans le
petit texte qu'ils aient soumis
pas un mot pas à morceau d'idées il ya
vous avez la vérité et les autres sont
dans les ténèbres
cette conception du vivre ensemble est
quelque chose que je ne peux jamais
partagé dans toute ma vie politique j'ai
toujours pensé que celle ou celui qui
est en face de bois pouvait détenir une
part de la vérité
et quand je vous ai entendu ce soir a
montré tout le contraire vous avez vous
la vérité vous êtes dans votre sphère
tous les autres sont dans les ténèbres
ce n'est pas cela je n'aurais jamais
pensé qu' une telle distance entre l'île
et vilaine et valence 1 et qu'en fait le
point d'ancrage était issoudun se
rappelle de temps passé me semble hors
de mise notre pays a besoin d'une
majorité d'une minorité et il a besoin
qu'on puisse discuter vous refuser de
discuter c'est votre choix
je le regrette profondément vous
pourriez dire que peut-être quand on
aurait trouvé des points d'accord des
points de discussion
vous avez choisi madame le président
borvo et des biens consubstantielle à
votre marxisme qui réapparaît de temps
en temps que vous disiez non mais il
vous arrive aussi de s'ouvrir
donc si c'est ainsi qu'elle entendait
des choses c'est votre choix
mais ça peut pas être le nôtre nous nous
considérons et je considère que
peut-être je n'ai pas complètement
raison et que s'il y avait eu une
discussion au sénat
eh bien le texte aurait été meilleur en
sortant du sénat
d'ailleurs vous avez fait un autre choix
et j'ai le droit de m'exprimer
et je continuerai à m'exprimer comme je
l ai toujours fait ici donc je regrette
beaucoup ce refus du débat parce que le
débat c'est pas la juxtaposition de 17
ou 18 discours le débat c'est s'écoute
et se répondre essayer de trouver des
avancées chez chacune et chacun
ceci dit je veux apporter juste quelques
mots de réponse sur l'article 6 qui a
fait l'objet de discussions et
rapporteur monsieur michel qui
d'ailleurs s'est drapé dans une tenue de
prince du bien et du mal dans mensonges
mensonges mensonges autres corps enfin
et bien pas peu du mensonge avoué le de
temps en temps et puis vous ne pouvez
pas tout savoir sur le mensonge monsieur
michel
ou alors il faut être un vrai
spécialiste et il faut être un vrai
spécialiste pour pouvoir en juger
ainsi voilà non mais et puis je
je voudrais également répondre à madame
catherine tasca un impressionnant tasca
que j'aime beaucoup
l'article 6 c'est est la mise en oeuvre
de deux décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
la première et c'est la designer d'une
qpc et qui a conduit le conseil
constitutionnel a un travail extrêmement
intéressant et monsieur le président
vous me pardonnerez mais cognac ya la
vraie est rappelons le conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 8
juillet 2011 a fixé une fois pour toutes
le contenu constitutionnelle du principe
fondamental reconnu par les lois de la
république en matière de justice des
videurs c'est donc cet apport la qui est
important parce que ça nous évitera à
chacun de sortir un drapeau en disant
ordonnance de 45 jeux déry pourquoi vous
refusez toujours des sites et la loi du
12 avril 1906 qui est une grande loi sur
la justice des mineurs qui étaient au
gouvernement à l'époque en 1906
clemenceau ou pas et on doit faire
quelque chose ou avoir rappelé sa
mémoire et son rôle dans cette affaire
ça vous rappellerai votre ancrage
radicales notamment
bon passons non mais et je suis là pour
ça et je vais oui mais et justement le
conseil national de la résistance
c'est la fin d'une époque pour le
conseil constitutionnel et le début pour
la nouvelle république
et c'est cela est le conseil national
istat
maintenant voilà monsieur mairie ce que
dit le conseil constitutionnel
considérant que l'atténuation de la
responsabilité pénale des mineurs en
fonction de l'âge comme la nécessité de
rechercher le relèvement éducatif et
moral des enfants délinquants par des
mesures adaptées à leur âge et à leur
personnalité prononcée par une
juridiction spécialisée où selon des
procédures appropriées ont été
constamment reconnu par les lois de la
république
depuis le début du xxème siècle que ces
principes trouve notamment leur
expression dans la loi du 12 avril 1906
sur la majorité pénale des mineurs
la loi du 22 juillet 1912 sur les
tribunaux pour enfants et l'ordonnancé
du 2 février 1945 sur l'enfance
délinquante que toutefois la législation
républicaine antérieure à l'entrée en
vigueur de la constitution de 1946 ne
consacre pas de règle selon laquelle les
mesures contraignantes ou les sanctions
devraient toujours être évitée au profit
de mesures purement éducative qu en
particulier les dispositions originel
d'une ordonnance du 2 février 1945
n'écartait pas la responsabilité pénale
des mineurs et n'excluait pas en cas de
nécessité que fussent prononcer à leur
égard des mesures telles que le
placement la surveillance la retenue ou
pour les mineurs de plus de 13 ans la
détention que telle est la portée du
principe fondamental reconnu par les
lois de la république en matière de jeu
this des mineurs je rappelle également
au sénat que l'article 62 de la
constitution dispose que les décisions
du conseil constitutionnel s'imposent à
tous c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a veillé à inscrire dans le
texte
cette disposition parce que certes comme
cela été enlevés nous avons jusqu'au 1er
janvier 2013 pour mettre en oeuvre ces
mesures
je veux simplement signalé à la haute
assemblée elle ne doit peut-être pas
l'ignorer que le parlement ne va plus
siéger à partir du 20 février jusqu'au
mois de juin qu'il est probable qu'au
mois de juin et il aura un certain
nombre de travaux de mise en route a
affaire qui aura une session
extraordinaire
comme chaque fois dans ces cas là et
qu'il y aura une majorité ce sont
ceux-là majorité que les français auront
choisi et si vous avez la même
conception du vivre ensemble que de dire
nous on a la vérité vous vous êtes
endettés d'être les français choisiront
du bon côté et ils choisiront ceux qui
parce que on peut partager des choses et
qu'on n'est pas exclue les uns des
autres ce que vous avez fait aujourd'hui
donc moi je fais confiance aux français
de ce côté là et ensuite il y aura très
naturellement un budget à voter des
mesures économiques et sociales que le
candidat élu président de la république
a fait valider qui seront mises en
oeuvre
pas le temps de mettre en oeuvre les
dispositions du conseil constitutionnel
avant décembre 2012 comme cela est
nécessaire pour la mise en oeuvre au 1er
janvier 2013 c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a choisi de faire maintenant
sur la seconde partie de l'article 6 le
procureur à tout moment de l'instruction
si des investigations sur la
personnalité sont suffisantes si des
investigations sur les faits ne sont
plus nécessaires peut requérir deux noms
de requérir du juge des enfants qui leur
donne la comparution du mineur dans un
délai compris entre 1 et 3 mois
l'amendement qui a été votée par
l'assemblée nationale
prévoit de raccourcir ce délai à dix
jours et entre dix jours et un mois
lorsque les mineurs récidivistes et âgés
de plus de 16 ans doit comparaître
devant un tribunal correctionnel des
mineurs puisqu'il est récidiviste il y a
déjà eu une enquête de personnalité
sinon il serait ce pas le cas le juge
des enfants disposent avec le texte qui
a été voté par l'assemblée nationale de
trois possibilités
1 faire droit à la demande du procureur
de refuser cette demande en application
de l'article 82 du code de procédure
pénal auquel l article 8 2 de
l'ordonnancé de 1945 renvoi et 3 qui
fera la plupart du temps ne rien faire
voilà ce que contient l'amendement
inquiète et voter est ce que contient
l'article 6 je pense que la méritait
d'être rappelé au sénat parce que c'est
pas du tout ce qui a été présenté sur le
fond de la ppn je veux pas reprendre
tout ce que j'ai dit dans des
dispositions mais honnêtement il s'agit
de quoi il s'agit simplement de donner
une possibilité nouvelle au juge des
enfants pour répondre à une situation
particulière dans laquelle vont se
trouver certains mineurs
primo-délinquants et vos passes et 1
contre 1 d'un service avec les people
hors du lit c'est affreux et lépide
c'est pas du tout le même public
il faudrait peut-être pas se moquer du
monde
jeudi dans le rapport de la plesse page
17 parce que j'essaye d'avoir les
lectures les plus diverses possibles
moi j'ai aucun problème donc un page 17
madame ps écrit si en principe ces
jeunes doivent jouir de leurs droits
civiques et pas avoir demain sur portet
au bulletin numéro deux du casier
judiciaire jugée incompatible et que
cette démarche
30% d'entre eux ils sont déjà dans les
epide 30% on est on néanmoins déjà été
jugé et 15% sont pour ceux qui sont déjà
dans les pid sont sous suivi judiciaire
c'est ce qui figure dans votre rapport
pagis
il m'est donc dire que c'est c'est le
même public
c'est tout et tout et bien si c'est le
il y aura 10 % de jeunes leaders rivaux
de lacan qui s'ils l'acceptent
s'ils le veulent bénéficieront de
l'action de l'epide avec un contrat
s'ils veulent parler les publierons dans
un foyer et seront pas mis en prison
comme le dit monsieur déry je rappelle
que ce gouvernement est le seul à avoir
fait baisser le nombre de mineurs en
prison parce qu'on a créé les centres
éducatifs fermés
encore faut-il rappeler la vérité et
honnêtement 4 bet et mineurs en prison
sèche c'est pas une gloire pour quelques
gouvernements que ce soit donc je ne
cherche pas du tout je cherche à faire
diminuer le nombre de mineurs en prison
et pour faire diminuer le nombre glisse
dans la prison il faut ouvrir d'autres
possibilités de mesures de placement de
foyers et ça c'est une mesure
supplémentaire
il ya 200 places qui seront offerts que
les magistrats pourront utiliser ou pas
utilisés que les jeunes pourront prendre
ou ne pas prendre et ça nous semble de
bonne mesure parce que c'est dans cet
épisode il y aura un encadrement fin par
d'anciens militaires mais ces panneaux
encadrement militaire san encadrement
civile fait par d'anciens militaires
il y à des éducateurs et il ya surtout
des représentants du monde industriel
économique artisanale qui vient former
les jeunes et les ados du pré formation
professionnelle honnêtement je vois pas
ce que l'on peut reprocher à ce système
en fait à rien c'est bien pour ça que
des y'a rien à lui reprocher vous avez
décidé de ne pas en parler
je ne regrette beaucoup
merci monsieur ministre la parole est à
monsieur sueur président de la
commission des lois
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai une
question à vous poser monsieur le
ministre mais auparavant
permettez moi de dire que j'ai été un
peu surpris vous dont je connais
l'attachement à la centralité des choses
de vous voir présenter ce débat que j'ai
trouvé pour ma part très riche très
argumentée de manière tellement
manichéenne allant même jusqu'à des
métonymie quelque peu douteuse parce
qu'enfin tous les habitants d'issoudun
ne seront pas marqué pour l'éternité par
la parole de l'un d'entre d'eux mêmes
monsieur le ministre que les habitants
de grenoble ne seront pas voué aux
gémonies parce qu'un discours a été tenu
un certain jour dans cette cité et
monsieur le ministre je voulais vous
dire en outre qu'il y à un certain
nombre de rhétorique relatives à la
question préalable qui me paraissent
quelque peu sujette à caution car j'ai
étudié les questions préalables que le
sénat avait dans sa grande sagesse voter
dans les périodes passées et je dois
vous dire que je tiens à votre
disposition une liste impressionnante
ainsi que toute la rhétorique sur le
thème mes chers collègues vous ne voulez
pas parler
c'eût été tellement mieux que
d'améliorer le texte donc la question
préalable fait partie des outils qui
sont dans notre constitution et qui sont
dans notre règlement
il est donc parfaitement légitime d'ange
dans nos usages mais monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous poser une
question précise car vous avez fourni un
certain nombre d'explications mais vous
n'avez pas répondu à plusieurs orateurs
qui vous ont interrogé sur la question
financière
les epide j'ai regardé les crédits dont
ils disposaient en 2010 99 millions 987
1000 euros en 2011
82 millions quatre cent trente mille
euros
donc on passe de 99,9 millions à 82,4
dans le budget 2012
je lis aussi le rapport de madame
claisse les deux plus grands
contributeurs au financement des epide
je veux dire le programme 102 accès et
retour à l'emploi et le programme 147
politique de la ville verront pour ce
qui est de leurs contributions au budget
de l'epide leurs crédits diminué
respectivement de 13 % et 12 %
donc ma question est très simple il y a
moins de crédits en 2011 qu'en 2010 il y
aura entre 12 et 13% de moins de crédits
en 2012 qu'en 2011 comment pouvez vous
imaginer sérieusement de confier de
nouvelles tâches aux epide
alors que leurs crédits diminuent ce
aussi fortement
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance à
suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par
trois avec comme invitée aujourd'hui à
la main qui est très bonne soirée à tous
moi je ne dis pas que d'être dirigeant
d'un parti goggin et ses serments à la
fonction suprême de notre pays mais y
être resté onze ans